[Music]
hi we're alive from the 2019 Wolfram
technology conference I'm Silvia Haas
and I'm Wolfram Alpha on Twitter and I'm
here with my co-host hi I'm Reggie I'm a
student at the Illinois Math and Science
Academy and part of the wolf emerging
Leaders program
I'm here with Carlo Barbieri who though
a consultant for welcome who's gonna
tell us all about relational databases
hi so what do you do oh I've been here a
few years now eight and I tell number of
things first started out in alpha then
moved on working on the Wolfram language
itself did some stuff from the cloud and
now the last and greatest project we've
been doing is about integrating SQL
databases in the Wolfram language so
well most of the functionality came out
with version 12 in April and so we were
trying to replace what was database link
that was a separate package for
interacting with SQL and you know as
it's very common in the Wolfram language
sometimes features start out as several
packages and then we integrate them more
closely with the rest of the language
and so they become you know when when
this tighter integration and more
polished design we finally understand
better what people need then we we bless
them as system packages and this what
happened it's been I have to say one of
the problems largest project I've work
on I work with the recovered in Virginia
who's another developer who works in
Rome where I am based and with Larry
Shivan who is from saint-petersburg seen
Berg learn it is a very long time
Mathematica user he's written one of the
best books and it's really been an honor
with the steam and so yeah relational
databases are one of the most mature and
long-standing technologies in computer
science like now there's been a trend
maybe 10 years ago where people wanted
to stop use SQL and start using no SQL
but that has killed me and now it's been
like as kill has been around for like 40
years and and there's like basically
every website you touch has an SQL
database behind it everybody who does
data science uses SQL it's truly
marvelous technology but it has a lot of
rough edges there's multiple database
vendors with slightly different dialects
and so basically for somebody who
approaches SQL from the outside it can
be a bit daunting and so what we're
trying to do is to bring a layer of
abstraction to to actually allow people
to interact in the same way with
databases such as SQLite which is file
based and usually Stein to things like
Postgres and which can be of the order
of terabytes of data so it's the first
time that mahadji has some truly out of
core data science what like type of
person would be use this well so for now
we only support reading from databases
so what you do is so for example there's
a large number of public datasets
in for example computational biology or
bioinformatics so things like gene
expressions and proteins they have it's
very large datasets that cannot possibly
fit in the memory of your peers so the
only way to interact with them is to
like perform some queries on the
database then what what our system
allows us people to do always true
you have some kind of a hybrid approach
to this kind of data science sorry you
first aggregate or filter the data to a
manageable size and then you can bring
it into Mathematica and and then you can
do all the crazy things that Mathematica
is able to do in terms of visualizations
and data analysis so it's like our our
stuff is like the first step in like
bringing leading to a manageable size
taking it in so yeah I imagine ever
anyone whose data scientist or work with
large amount and and actually the path
is to allow this stuff available also to
people for example want to develop their
websites or move from cloud and so it
would be useful also for for example if
you have a form and the bases are joints
so as soon as we support right then
there will be also that big segment can
this be like integrated with projects
like now like if you want to learn about
it there places to do this yeah so well
good places so there are two good places
to start one is
kind of more of a brief introduction and
it's if you go to the wall from dot-com
web page there's a you can click on
verse from 12 and it's gonna bring this
whole the marketing pages and there's
one on relational databases where there
are a few examples that I I won't with
with recover line it and for example one
of them is exactly about this gene
expression data bases and it shows how
is the how one with to find a public
data set to analyze the second path
which is more I mean it is a lot more
in-depth is there is a tutorial about
relational databases that has been
written entirely by Lonnie and it's I
mean I once tried to see to print it as
a as a PDF file it's over 100 pages so
it's really more more than sorry it's
really small book about this way and
while it doesn't provide people with
super interesting data you have to bring
your own basic interesting things but it
has much more complicated queries and it
doesn't very much in that into what is
possible what the limitations are what
are the tricks right so you are building
well one thing I'm excited about and
it's something that I discovered while I
was writing the documentation pages is
basically within the company we have a
lot of functionality that's related to
Geographics
francisco but all the excellent mapping
functionality and talking on that is
done using the software that is called I
mean behind the scenes just and that's
what we know how it works and so
basically we have inside the company we
have our own instance our own copy of
instruments to support all the things
and so he gave me access to that because
I wanted to write some example on some
really big database that's for a
terabyte and I started playing with it
and at first like when I was doing the
marketing pages I found some stuff that
was interesting like I was counting how
many trees are mapped throughout the
world in the oldest project or I was
counting how many streets with the
Wolfram string within the name and so a
part existed before 200 something and
and so but it was all very dry because
all the the actual mapping abilities
were were impossible to reach because
those are actually extension to the SQL
language and they have like their own
specific domain specific language to do
that stuff that obviously we can support
is exported only in that very nice thing
and what we've been in recently and
which is something that we're gonna add
to version 4.1 is that we allow people
to insert their own verbatim SQL strings
in the middle of a more complex
generated plan and so basically I
started experimenting with the actual
functions and so now I can not only find
the streets that contain warfarin the
name
and actually compute the length find the
longest one and then lamp it because you
can return geo JSON that make animals
awfully important - I think this is
really like now that we are bridging the
gap between the cat abilities this
everybody wants and so we make them that
simple to integrate do the things that
maybe work on on a very nice vendor and
so we will never put there in front
because then it will not work most of
the time actually will make sense yeah
you can start doing like really advanced
data analysis on data sets that are a
thousands of times larger than the RAM
of my machine so you mentioned being
able to write and other things for the
databases is there anything else for the
future well right into database is a
really big project yeah what we're so
one of the projects that I worked before
at the company was actually all the
things that are related to API functions
and form functions
interpreter the powers function and one
thing that would want to do that yeah
actually and in mind when first start
working up with form function is that in
a sense a form is a pretty close
representation of a database role so
what we want to be able to do and this
is probably not going to be 12.1 is
going to be the following relief is to
take in our case so a database table is
usually represented as an entity type
take an entity type feed to a form and
get out automatically a website for data
entry so so what we want to do is like
to bridge together a project that we
started now five years ago which is
forms of api's which are largely the
same thing one is an interface for
humans and the other is an interface for
computers and use those
to generate a very simple website that
allows you to say okay let's say I have
a customer that are they stable and I
need to fill in the first name last name
and then maybe add a drop-down menu with
the department they work for so all
those things are things that should be
that simple to integrate together
because we've been designing them with a
kind of a holistic approach which i
think is really one of wolfram strengths
as company that you know it's not like
somebody is going the wrong direction
somebody else is like a idea that has
been largely the same for the past
thirty years about what the design of
the language should be and what are the
common principles and and how all should
fit together very tightly so I I'm very
excited about this development and I
hope it will come out as well thank you
so much for coming in and talking
[Music]